[Music]
we haven't talked about mcdonald's in
quite some time
very true but true yes but did you guys
hear
about this oreo spam burger they were
selling and
yeah i that was crazy yeah did it
taste good oh i saw it that's something
i thought it was actually
pretty good yeah he'll try anything like
the fungus off your foot what's what's
that is that mayonnaise
please tell me that's not mayonnaise
that's the oreo cream no it's not the
oreo cream apparently it's some sauce
that they usually put on their burgers
it looks really weird but i would try it
but it doesn't look like um
something we'll try to get full off of
just like a novelty bite
yeah i mean my own boogers so i'm okay
i'll try it
yeah i would totally try it i would for
sure try it too but it just does not
seem very appetizing
no it does not it just seems like a
weird combination
like why did you like what was the
thought process behind this like a child
invented it
yeah this is something that they curated
for the advertisement
and you know when you get your
sandwiches from mcdonald's it looks like
[ __ ] compared to the advertising yeah so
i can only imagine what it would look
like in person you're right
this kind of looks like a communist
poster too for some reason
i see it where no the destructive
nation yeah that looks like oh my god
yeah
we got well somebody ripped it off the
wall and that's what was behind a new
poster
which is the money sign you know oh i
see nowadays thanks to capitalism which
one
you get like a little square of that
like this big and you pay like 35
i have one i own a piece that my mother
gave me when she was in there you go
capitalism one i saw a piece of the
berlin wall when i was in portland maine
cool they have a piece a big slab
i was walking around looking at boats
and i said what the hell is that big-ass
stone and they said this is the wall
that we should not forget
it divided can you touch it yeah so
people want to spray paint
this easily yeah there's already spray
paint on it that's [ __ ] up
it really is it's like i saw the berlin
wall in my bathroom
no i have it in my bedroom oh there you
go why
and you're right there is graffiti on it
because i have two berlin wall pieces
you bought it if i bought a stein in
germany then on the top
it wasn't how do they have so much
pieces of water there's a huge
it's only been 31 years like they don't
didn't run out they built that and trump
can't build this wall
tell me about it it's probably lazy you
couldn't build one i did that [ __ ]
really quick
yeah true but anyway back to mcdonald's
here
so like i said i can i can tell you the
thought process behind why they thought
this was a good idea
uh the communications manager of
mcdonald's in china said
luncheon meat spam is a trending food
among youngsters nowadays
it has a very strong meaty and
satisfying texture the flavor
the flavorful and crispy oreo on the
other hand is a snack
youngsters are familiar with by
creatively combining the two foods it
doesn't only showcase the collision of
tastes and textures
it's also quite topical socially
his logic is so [ __ ] dumb because
that's like serving coke with french
fries inside of them
huh oh they like this why don't we put
them together
this is how hollywood literally works
how so like we took fast and the furious
and we combined it with back to the
future and what's that what's the movie
is going back in time and then what's
the movie that's the third movie it
doesn't matter
that's what that's that's what the movie
is the fast i want to watch that
but that's what i'm saying back to the
faster whatever what's it called back to
the fast i like that
but that's what i'm saying that's what
they do they just take two successful
things put them together and say
this is the new move michelle rodriguez
flies back in time and then vin diesel
catches him in a nice outfit
that's pretty good we played a game on
jk party where we would draw
cards and we would have to come up with
movie plots and it was random [ __ ] like
yeah yeah
yeah i like spam i like oreos play all
day they're just like
just hey this was very successful what
if and this was very successful we put
them together
that's what they're doing that's exactly
how this [ __ ] works that's what a ranged
marriage is like though
that's very successful too you're
successful
except for my grandma that ended up in
divorce oh it didn't work out
well yeah so this this one time
in arranged marriages yeah the one thing
because usually they're shamed to not
divorce
exactly my grandma was a little renegade
but yeah
so this hamburger here was sold for only
one day in china
i don't call that a hammer and no one
wanted to eat it i call that a
a sandwich a spam burger that should
have just been a spam burger without the
oreo it's like yo
uh mcdonald's is also collaborating with
spam they did too much
that's true i just feel bad for like the
guy that was like we should make a spam
burger and then someone else chimed in
with oreos and then it failed
immediately
then they fired the guy that brought the
spam it was a woman
what that invented the spam she didn't
invent it she's a communications manager
for mcdonald's in china okay
yeah or what if that was it happened on
the day where they had that one company
they were like
all ideas are good today and someone
goes oreo and they're like
[ __ ] why did it have to be today or was
this
a comedian's burger that he partnered
with i like that one
it's like it's like our version of the
tom segura burger where he's like
nobody's gonna eat this [ __ ]
and they put oreo with spaghetti they
made 400 000.
oh my god andy and no one got it no no
they had it available at about 3 700
branches across china
and no one bought it and it sold out by
noon oh [ __ ]
it's limited time dude why didn't they
only they want to try new [ __ ]
see we [ __ ] up we didn't listen to you
on bitcoin right
give us your next best idea okay buy my
new coin smx
no no you come up with a spam oreo
burger oh right right right sure um
okay you know what i would actually
think is delicious tasting
i love barbecue sauce okay but i would
put a patty in barbecue sauce on both
sides
okay i put that on between the buns but
it has to be king's hawaiian rolls don't
even [ __ ] with me
i knew you were going there pepper jack
is the cheese but you could also do
american brie cheese oh i mean yeah but
i know that'd be worse okay we'll do
provolone slice of provolone on top
with a little bit of pepper jack in the
middle
okay and then it comes with french fries
already
in between oh yes yes thank you
how come no burger place i actually
served thank you
uh french fries it's not the birthday
sounds pretty good no they they do that
for burritos and they call them
california burritos and these those are
very good too and people order them
right but nobody does the [ __ ] for
burgers yeah just put it they got lomo
saltado
i like to do it myself yeah but that's
that's not a burger what i'm saying but
they got it down we're like hey
the fries are here and the meat's right
next to it let's just
put it together i also do is like this
much
tapatio oh just a little dash like
that's it and that's you doing it
without the top yeah there's no top on
it
well they don't know that for this
burger was anyone
uh stabbed or shot in line waiting for
it
you heard about this no because in
america people were stabbed and shot
for waiting for the popeyes chicken
burger i heard that yeah
why do americans embarrass us so much
americans are dumb
so do we actually we embarrass ourselves
i don't know i think americans are great
we are americans too
that you guys see embarrassment i see
go-getters
uh to stab and kill people for because
he was like this burger i'll
kill for this burger right they just
kill people for chicken though we also
kill them for black friday deals that's
true
and i also saw a girl take a dump in
line
in a washing machine because she didn't
want to wait and get out of line
i watched a girl take a pee in the
street one time because she had to go to
the bathroom in her own car and didn't
want to go inside of her car
um uh this guy waited in line
for two days um for i think was best buy
uh because i think was best buy or one
of those places um
and people were like they they
interviewed him for they're like oh why
are you waiting in line for like the
black fire deals because no i just need
a
[ __ ] extension cable
for like like two days later he could
have been that's a lie
i swear this was like a real thing who
would be that stupid to stand there for
two days
i'm americans i pissed people okay
couple years don't get mad when we say
that a couple years ago i did a video
where i i went to the launch of the xbox
one and
the playstation or whatever and i went
and lined up for the xbox one like
within the first like couple hours that
they said
to line up for oh i saw this video yeah
and then i left
i asked the guy i was like hey can you
save my spot i gotta go real quick i'll
be right back
and he's like sure i came back like five
and a half hours later
and then i i like pushed my way through
the line and i go to the guy i'm like
thank you so much for saving my spot and
that's it he never says anything he's
just kind of sitting there steaming and
[ __ ]
and i'm like oh my god like i had to go
home and take a shower and like
like i had to go hang out i can't be in
line for too long i go crazy
yeah yeah yeah exactly that's the whole
point of the video and then
eventually like what a nice guy though
yeah yeah so i did that early i did that
like three
and this was like 7 30 and i was like
you know what i'm sorry i have to go
again i'll be right back
and i was like i'll be right right right
back and then i left again and i came
back at 11
45 at night just before like it opens at
midnight
wow and un unfortunately before i got to
push my way through the line and do all
the [ __ ]
they had already let everyone inside
because it was raining
did see that coming did you want the
xbox though huh did you want the xbox
no i didn't give a [ __ ] i was just gonna
do a video that's [ __ ] hilarious they
were all everyone was so
[ __ ] pissed that i pushed my waist he
came back this guy made it legit because
i was like
oh no he knows like it's all chill guys
anyways
oh it's so cold out here like i don't
want to be out here for too long
what a troll now the one i thought you
were going to talk about was the one
where you dropped
the new oh yeah the playstation 1 yeah
playstation i saw that video
oh yeah that was that one did much
better but i dropped i dropped the
playstation like this much
like i basically just my buddy richard
ryan who's a very popular
um he shoots all kinds of technology and
[ __ ] he had already gotten the
playstation 4 through taco bell so he
shot that thing with a [ __ ] 50 cal
and like looks nuts so when you open the
[ __ ] thing and look at it
it looks nuts and so i already had the
box and like i had the playstation
so i walked i walked into like a best
buy and then i walked out with it
and everyone's in line and they're like
wait what the [ __ ] dude and i cuz i
already had the place before i'm like
oh yeah i know i hate lines so i just
went in and got it like whatever and
they're all like
what the [ __ ] is going on and then they
i just kept walking and i
like dropped it barely like when i say
it barely my arms are already long so i
just
barely dropped it it must have fallen
two inches and hit the ground i'm like
oh [ __ ]
and then i opened it up and it looks so
nuts
then i'm like yo what the [ __ ] this is
so [ __ ] i'm like guys don't buy this
[ __ ]
like you you drop it one time is like it
falls apart like a [ __ ] cookie
that's [ __ ] crazy they're like i
can't believe this [ __ ] what are we
doing
they were like is this real is that real
yeah they had no idea it was fun
you